Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. As thou art to this hour was Richard then, when I from France set foot at Ravensburg. And even as I was then is Percy now. Now by my sceptre and my soul to boot, he hath more worthy interest to the state than thou, the shadow of succession. For of no right, no colour like to write, he doth fill fields with harness in the realm, turns head against the lion's armoured jaws, and being no more in debt to years than thou, leads ancient lords and reverend
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。正如理查德当时在雷文斯堡从法国登陆时那样，你现在也是如此。而正如我当时那样，珀西现在也是如此。现在，凭我的权杖和灵魂起誓，比起你这个继承权的影子，他对国家有着更值得的利益。因为他没有任何权利，没有任何理由，却在王国里填满了武装，对抗狮子那披甲的利颚，而且他并不比你年长，却带领着古老的领主和受人尊敬的
bishops on to bloody battles and to bruising arms. So it's 1403. Henry IV has been brought the news that his old comrade, Harry Hotspur, Harry Percy, is in revolt against him. So is Owen Glyndaur in Wales. There is trouble in Scotland. It is all kicking off. And at this moment, Tom, Henry IV has summoned his dissolute son, Prince Hal, from a tavern in Cheapside. And he says to him, listen, you are like Richard II. You are like that drip that I had to kick off the throne. And Harry Hotspur, your arch rival, your nemesis, is like I was back then then he is poised to take over and look at what degradation you have brought our family to with your carousings with full staff and all this
主教们走向血腥的战场和残酷的搏斗。所以现在是1403年。亨利四世接到消息，他的老战友哈里·霍特斯珀（即哈里·珀西）正在反叛他。威尔士的欧文·格林道尔也是如此。苏格兰也出现了动乱。一切都乱套了。就在这时，汤姆，亨利四世从奇普赛德的一家酒馆里召回了他那放荡的儿子哈尔王子。他对他说，听着，你就像理查德二世。你就像我不得不赶下王位的那种废物。而你的死对头、你的宿敌哈里·霍特斯珀，就像当年的我一样，他准备接管一切，看看你因为和福斯塔夫以及这些人鬼混，把我们的家族带到了何种堕落的地步
in our hour of need in the hour of darkness but tom's being a bit unfair isn't it yeah you think this is a bit harsh don't you it's a bit it was certainly in the context of the play because the prince of wales prince how i mean he tells his dad, look, I'm going to, I'm going to meet Hotspur in battle. I'm going to kill him and I will redeem all this on Percy's head. So in other words, all Percy's great achievements, they will then accrue to me. Yeah, but who would believe that? All he's been doing is drinking for the last like six years or something. Well, he pulls it off in the play. But I think it's also unfair in reality because as we mentioned in the previous episode, Henry IV part one, the prince isn't actually the
在我们最需要的时候，在黑暗的时刻，但汤姆，这有点不公平，不是吗？是的，你觉得这有点苛刻，对吧？这确实有点，至少在戏剧的语境下是这样，因为威尔士亲王，哈尔王子，我的意思是，他告诉他父亲，看，我会在战场上会会霍特斯珀。我会杀了他，我会把这一切都算在珀西的头上。换句话说，珀西所有的伟大成就，都将归于我。是的，但谁会相信呢？他过去六年左右的时间里一直在喝酒。嗯，他在戏里成功了。但我认为在现实中这也并不公平，因为正如我们在上一集《亨利四世（第一部）》中提到的，王子实际上并不
same age as Hotspur. I mean, that's what Henry IV is saying, but actually Hotspur was older than Henry IV himself. And not only that, but the prince really hadn't been hanging out in taverns. He's been having this very, very grueling apprenticeship in Wales. So on the 12th of July, when Henry IV has brought the news of Hotspur's rebellion, and he's in Nottingham on his way up to Scotland, Henry, his elder son, the Prince of Wales, is two months off his 17th birthday. And he has essentially been fighting the Welsh for three years. So at the age of 14, he'd been sent to Chester, which had been an absolute hotbed of Ricardian support.
和霍特斯珀同龄。我的意思是，亨利四世是这么说的，但实际上霍特斯珀比亨利四世本人还要年长。不仅如此，王子其实并没有在酒馆里鬼混。他在威尔士经历了一段非常、非常艰苦的学徒生涯。所以7月12日，当亨利四世接到霍特斯珀叛乱的消息，并且他在前往苏格兰的途中经过诺丁汉时，他的长子、威尔士亲王亨利离他17岁生日还有两个月。他实际上已经和威尔士人打了三年仗了。所以14岁时，他被派往切斯特，那里曾是理查德二世支持者的绝对温床。
It's the great place for longbowmen in England. So a place that Henry needs to kind of make sure is behind him. Then he's had Owen Glyndaw's revolt. Owen Glyndaw has proclaimed himself Prince of Wales. So a direct rival to Prince Hal. And the two Princes of Wales have started kind of hammering at each other. And on the 1st of April 1403, the Prince, who by that point has become of age, is given official command of the war. And he's shown himself, even though he's only 16, he's pretty good. I mean, he's a pretty proficient commander.
那是英格兰长弓手的好地方。所以亨利需要确保这个地方支持他。然后是欧文·格林道尔的叛乱。欧文·格林道尔自封为威尔士亲王。所以他是哈尔王子的直接竞争对手。两位威尔士亲王开始互相攻击。1403年4月1日，当时已经成年的王子被正式授予战争指挥权。他表现出了自己的能力，尽管他只有16岁，但他相当不错。我的意思是，他是一位相当精干的指挥官。
So he's, we mentioned in the last episode, he's wasted Owen Glyndaw's manors in the northeast of Wales. He's relieved sieges of Harlech and Aberystwyth Castle. And I think also this is full of moment for the future his future career he is getting to grips with the fact that you can't fight battles without money you know the sinews of war are gold and even as he's fighting he's also started writing letters to his father saying look we need more money and he writes to henry the fourth and says we have made all the pawning we may of our little jewels to defray the debts. So he's putting his jewels where his mouth is. He's really understanding
所以，正如我们在上一集提到的，他摧毁了欧文·格林道尔在威尔士东北部的庄园。他解除了哈莱赫城堡和阿伯里斯特威斯城堡的围困。我认为这对他的未来职业生涯至关重要，他开始意识到没有钱是打不了仗的，你知道，战争的筋骨是黄金，即使在战斗中，他也开始写信给父亲说，看，我们需要更多的钱，他写信给亨利四世说，我们已经把我们所有的小珠宝都典当了，以偿还债务。所以他是在用实际行动说话。他真正理解了
that war is about logistics as well as about strategy and tactics. Now, it is true that in this apprenticeship, Henry IV has a very, very good guardian who is Thomas Percy, the Earl of Worcester, who is the uncle of Harry Hotspur, the younger brother of Northumberland, and he is on hand to kind of guide the young prince. I don't think it alters the fact. Yeah, it doesn't alter the fact that he's a very, very impressive young man already. So for two years, he's been in the field and he's been getting to grips with not just battlefield tactics and stuff, but basically the organization, the political organization and economic organization that goes into warfare. And those will be enormously important for him when he becomes Henry V, as we will see next week. And takes the fight to a more formidable enemy.
战争不仅关乎战略和战术，也关乎后勤。现在，确实在这段学徒生涯中，亨利四世有一位非常、非常好的监护人，那就是伍斯特伯爵托马斯·珀西，他是哈里·霍特斯珀的叔叔，诺森伯兰的弟弟，他在身边指导这位年轻的王子。我不认为这改变了一个事实。是的，这并没有改变他已经是一位非常、非常令人印象深刻的年轻人的事实。所以两年来，他一直在前线，他不仅掌握了战场战术之类的东西，而且基本上掌握了战争背后的组织，即政治组织和经济组织。当他明年成为亨利五世时，这些对他来说将极其重要，正如我们下周将看到的。并将战斗带给更强大的敌人。
Yeah. And as Henry V, of course, he will fight a great war and he will face stupefying odds. And now, in the summer of 1403, he is also facing terrifying odds because Hotspur has turned against Henry IV, has turned against the House of Lancaster, has arrived in Chester, just to the north of where the Prince of Wales is in Shrewsbury. And Hotspur is proclaiming that King Richard is alive, that he's the rightful king, which means that the young prince is in deadly peril of being cornered. So if that's the case, right, Hotspur is saying, for understandable reasons, time to get rid of the usurper. King Richard is alive.
是的。作为亨利五世，他当然会打一场伟大的战争，他将面对惊人的困难。现在，在1403年的夏天，他也面临着可怕的困难，因为霍特斯珀已经背叛了亨利四世，背叛了兰开斯特家族，已经抵达了切斯特，就在威尔士亲王所在的什鲁斯伯里以北。霍特斯珀宣称理查德国王还活着，他是合法的国王，这意味着这位年轻的王子正处于被围困的致命危险之中。所以如果是这样的话，对吧，霍特斯珀说，出于可以理解的原因，是时候除掉篡位者了。理查德国王还活着。
I will lead the crusade to put him back on. I know crusade is the wrong word, but anyway, I will lead the campaign to put him back on his throne. Does he have a Richard II? Does he have a pretender in his baggage? Because that's going to be a problem if he wins. So there is this pretender up in Scotland, the kitchen boy who is claiming to be Richard II. But there is also young Edmund Mortimer, who is being kept in silken captivity in Windsor, who, in the opinion of many people, has a better claim to the throne than Henry IV. And Hotspur is married to Edmund Mortimer's aunt.
我将领导十字军东征让他复位。我知道十字军这个词用得不对，但不管怎样，我将领导这场运动让他重回王位。他行李里有理查德二世吗？他有一个冒充者吗？因为如果他赢了，那将是个问题。所以苏格兰那边确实有一个冒充者，那个自称是理查德二世的厨房男孩。但也有年轻的埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他被软禁在温莎的丝绸囚笼里，在许多人看来，他比亨利四世更有权继承王位。而霍特斯珀娶了埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姑姑。
So there is a family link between Hotspur and the potential new king. And I think almost certainly the Hotspur is planning to put this young boy on the throne. But then what would he do about his claim about Richard II being alive? I think he'd probably bury it. The reason he's making that claim is he's in Chester, where everyone in Chester absolutely loves Richard II. Richard II had always lavished great favour and attention on Chester. And the other reason he's doing that is that the people in Chester, as you said, they have this tremendous record of longbowmen. And this is what Harry wants to recruit. It's a region with a long record of service in France in the Hundred Years' War, under Edward III, under the Black Prince.
所以霍特斯珀和潜在的新国王之间有家族联系。我认为几乎可以肯定，霍特斯珀计划把这个小男孩推上王位。但那样的话，他关于理查德二世还活着的说法该怎么办？我想他可能会把它掩盖起来。他之所以那样说，是因为他在切斯特，那里的人绝对热爱理查德二世。理查德二世一直对切斯特给予极大的恩宠和关注。他这样做的另一个原因是，切斯特的人民，正如你所说，他们有着长弓手的辉煌记录。而这正是哈里想要招募的。这是一个在百年战争中，在爱德华三世和黑太子的领导下，有着长期服役记录的地区。
And in fact, the key figure in helping Hotspur to recruit men in Cheshire is a guy called John Massey, who's a knight from Tatton, who'd served with the Black Prince. And he comes and he joins Hotspur with his two sons. He brings lots of retainers with him. So that's brilliant. But of course, Hotspur has also been serving in Wales, where he had been very keen on accommodating Welsh aspirations rather than opposing them, as Henry IV had done. So there are people in Wales also who are very willing to rally to his cause.
事实上，帮助霍特斯珀在柴郡招募士兵的关键人物是一个叫约翰·马西的人，他是塔顿的一名骑士，曾随黑太子服役。他带着他的两个儿子加入了霍特斯珀。他带来了许多随从。所以这很棒。但当然，霍特斯珀也曾在威尔士服役，在那里他非常热衷于顺应威尔士的愿望，而不是像亨利四世那样反对他们。所以威尔士也有人非常愿意支持他的事业。
So even though he had turned up in Chester with only 160 men, he brought them from Northumberland, he very soon has an army numbering in the thousands, maybe 5,000, 6,000. Right. So this is looking pretty bleak for Prince Al, right? His father is a long way away because his father's been marching north. Yeah. So where is he? He's in the Welsh marches or on the border somewhere. No, he's in Shrewsbury. In Shrewsbury. But that is the Welsh marches. Yeah. He's camped out in Shrewsbury. Yeah. And compounding his danger is, of course, I just said that his guardian,
所以尽管他出现在切斯特时只有160人，他是从诺森伯兰带来的，但他很快就拥有了一支数千人的军队，也许有5000或6000人。对。所以这对哈尔王子来说看起来相当惨淡，对吧？他的父亲离得很远，因为他的父亲一直在向北进军。是的。那么他在哪里？他在威尔士边境或边界的某个地方。不，他在什鲁斯伯里。在什鲁斯伯里。但那是威尔士边境。是的。他驻扎在什鲁斯伯里。是的。而且加剧他危险的是，当然，我刚才说他的监护人，
his second in command, is the Earl of Worcester, Hotspur's uncle. And it's not yet clear what his take is. The Prince of Wales is relying on him to stay loyal, but he doesn't. So as Hotspur has recruited, you know, he's raised his army
他的副手，是伍斯特伯爵，霍特斯珀的叔叔。目前还不清楚他的立场。威尔士亲王指望他保持忠诚，但他没有。所以当霍特斯珀招募了，你知道，他集结了他的军队
and is now advancing south from Chester towards Shrewsbury, which is only about, what, 40 miles south, I think. And as he's doing this, the Earl of Worcester slips out of Shrewsbury. He has taken up 800 archers from the prince's retinue with him. So the prince is now even more denuded, even more stripped of men, basically only has about 1,000, maybe 1,200 men with him. And about a thousand, maybe 1200 men with him. And he's got this vast army descending on him. And when the rebels approach the outskirts of Shrewsbury, um, late on, uh, uh, the 19th of July, 1403, there's nothing really that the prince can
现在正从切斯特向南推进到什鲁斯伯里，我想只有大约40英里远。当他这样做时，伍斯特伯爵溜出了什鲁斯伯里。他带走了王子随从中的800名弓箭手。所以王子现在更加孤立，更加缺乏人手，基本上只有大约1000，也许1200人跟随他。而且大约有一千，也许1200人跟随他。他有一支庞大的军队向他压来。当叛军接近什鲁斯伯里郊区时，嗯，在1403年7月19日深夜，王子真的没有什么
do to oppose them. You know, Hotspur's army is able to kind of lay waste a few outskirts, things like that. But there's nothing that the prince can do. He's defiant. And he's 16, right? Yeah, he's almost 17. He's very young and he's facing this enormous army. Now, if he gets captured, that's very bad. It's probably, you know, terminus for him.
能做的来对抗他们。你知道，霍特斯珀的军队能够摧毁一些郊区，诸如此类的事情。但王子无能为力。他很反抗。他才16岁，对吧？是的，他快17岁了。他非常年轻，面对着这支庞大的军队。现在，如果他被俘虏，那就非常糟糕了。这对他来说可能就是终点。
He will be dispatched. The situation looks incredibly bleak, except there is one ray of sunshine, one advantage that the Lancastrians have. And that is because the Percys do not know where Henry IV is. They think he is in London. And London is too far away. Yeah. Multiple days march.
他会被处决。局势看起来极其惨淡，除了有一线希望，兰开斯特派有一个优势。那就是珀西家族不知道亨利四世在哪里。他们认为他在伦敦。而伦敦太远了。是的。多天的路程。
Yeah. For Henry to come and relieve Shrewsbury. But in fact, as we said at the end of the last episode, he's been marching northwards to Scotland and the news had reached him in Nottingham. And the moment he gets it, he starts marching towards the Welsh marches. So on the 19th of July, even as Hotspur's troops are massing on the outskirts of Shrewsbury, the King is about 30 miles away in Lichfield. And he has brought news that his son is in desperate peril.
是的。亨利无法赶来解救什鲁斯伯里。但事实上，正如我们在上一集结尾所说，他一直在向北进军苏格兰，消息在诺丁汉传到了他那里。他一得到消息，就开始向威尔士边境进军。所以7月19日，就在霍特斯珀的军队在什鲁斯伯里郊区集结时，国王在约30英里外的利奇菲尔德。他带来了消息说他的儿子处于极度危险之中。
And so they make a massive forced march through the night. And by the 20th of July, Henry's army has arrived outside Shrewsbury. The prince is able to join up with him, and the two armies are facing each other. And Hotspur realizes that his intelligence has been faulty. He drops back, retreats a few miles northwest. The king's army advances northwest to follow him, camps out in the vicinity of a great abbey to the northwest. And they're now about seven miles apart that evening.
于是他们彻夜进行了大规模的强行军。到7月20日，亨利的军队抵达了什鲁斯伯里外。王子得以与他会合，两军对峙。霍特斯珀意识到他的情报有误。他后撤，向西北退了几英里。国王的军队向西北推进跟随他，在西北的一座大修道院附近扎营。那天晚上他们相距约七英里。
And then the next day, the next morning, the 21st of July, which is a Saturday, the two armies slowly advanced towards each other till they were within sight of each other, but not within the reach of their arrows. Amazing scenes, Tom. So as yet, they're not ready to clash. And the king and Worcester, they hold a parley. This happens in the play, Henry IV, part one. And the Percy's bottom line is that Henry stand down and accept Edmund Mortimer as king. So there's your answer as to who they want. They're not really going for Richard II.
然后第二天，7月21日，星期六，两军缓慢地向对方推进，直到他们能看到对方，但还没到箭程之内。惊人的场景，汤姆。所以目前，他们还没准备好交战。国王和伍斯特进行了谈判。这发生在《亨利四世（第一部）》的戏里。珀西家族的底线是亨利下台并接受埃德蒙·莫蒂默为国王。所以这就是他们想要谁的答案。他们并不是真的想要理查德二世。
They're going for Edmund Mortimer. And obviously there's no way that Henry IV can accept this. They're wasting their lives making that offer. Absolutely. I mean, he's Henry IV can accept this. They're wasting their lives making that offer. Absolutely. I mean, he's never going to accept that. At the same time, the Percys can't really trust the king when he says that he'll forgive them. They know that he will finish them off very quickly if they do that.
他们想要的是埃德蒙·莫蒂默。显然亨利四世不可能接受这一点。他们是在浪费生命提出那个条件。绝对是。我的意思是，他亨利四世不可能接受这一点。他们是在浪费生命提出那个条件。绝对是。我的意思是，他永远不会接受。与此同时，珀西家族在国王说会宽恕他们时，并不能真正信任他。他们知道如果他们那样做，他会很快除掉他们。
But Worcester nevertheless continues the negotiations and it becomes increasingly clear to Henry that Worcester is essentially playing for time. And the reason for that is that because it's a Saturday, if Worcester can keep the parley going until dusk, the following day will be a Sunday and it's forbidden by the church for armies to fight on the Sunday. So you'd then be looking at Monday and it's possible that even more reinforcements might come by that time, maybe from Owen Glendower, maybe from the North, maybe from Chester,
但伍斯特仍然继续谈判，亨利越来越清楚伍斯特基本上是在拖延时间。原因是因为今天是星期六，如果伍斯特能把谈判拖到黄昏，第二天就是星期日，教会禁止军队在星期日作战。所以你就会看到星期一，到那时可能会有更多的增援部队到来，也许来自欧文·格林道尔，也许来自北方，也许来自切斯特，
who knows. And so Henry IV isn't having any of this because he probably outnumbers the rebels who are what, five, six thousand. He probably outnumbers them two to one. Nevertheless, the rebels do have advantages. So they have all these archers from Cheshire, and they're the best archers in England. They have highly seasoned commanders.
谁知道呢。所以亨利四世不吃这一套，因为他的人数可能超过了叛军，叛军有多少，五六千人。他的人数可能比他们多两倍。尽管如此，叛军确实有优势。他们有所有来自柴郡的弓箭手，他们是英格兰最好的弓箭手。他们有经验丰富的指挥官。
So they've got Hotspur. They've got Worcester. And they have the Earl of Douglas, who was a terrifying Scottish nobleman who'd been taken prisoner by Hotspur a year earlier, but has now come down with him and is keen to have a crack at the English king.
所以他们有霍特斯珀。他们有伍斯特。他们还有道格拉斯伯爵，他是一位可怕的苏格兰贵族，一年前被霍特斯珀俘虏，但现在和他一起下来，渴望挑战英格兰国王。
Why not? They basically said to him, you know, let's bury the hatchet and why don't you give us a hand? Yeah. Just to give people a sense. So they're on the higher ground. Yes. And as a structure native myself, I have to say the battlefield of Shrewsbury is an excellent
为什么不呢？他们基本上对他说，你知道，让我们言归于好，你为什么不帮我们一把？是的。只是为了让人们有个概念。所以他们在高地上。是的。作为一名什鲁斯伯里本地人，我必须说什鲁斯伯里的战场是一个非常好的
battlefield to visit. Tom? It is, yes. It's got a tremendous farm shop. It has a bird of prey center, if you like birds of prey. And on the other side of the road is the 2 Henry's Pub and Grill. So that's nice. And I think you can get hot spur honey, can't you?
值得参观的战场。汤姆？是的，确实。它有一个很棒的农场商店。如果你喜欢猛禽，它有一个猛禽中心。马路对面是“二亨利”酒吧和烧烤店。所以那很不错。我想你可以买到霍特斯珀蜂蜜，对吧？
You can get all, it's all black branded stuff. It's a great farm shop complex. Nice butchers, very good stuff in jars. Love it. And they've got a little exhibition. Yeah. It's actually a very good exhibition about the battle. And you can see the lay of the land, can't you?
你可以买到所有的，都是黑色的品牌产品。这是一个很棒的农场商店综合体。不错的肉店，罐子里有很多好东西。喜欢它。他们还有一个小展览。是的。关于这场战斗的展览实际上非常好。你可以看到地形，对吧？
You can see the hill. You totally can. And you can see why, you know, Henry might have hesitated at the thought of advancing up it because it's potentially treacherous ground, not just because it's high, but because there's a pea field. And these peas, there are lots of stakes
你可以看到那座山。你完全可以看到。你可以看到为什么，你知道，亨利在考虑向上推进时可能会犹豫，因为这不仅因为它是高地，而且因为有一片豌豆地。这些豌豆，有很多木桩
that have been driven into the ground and the peas have kind of grown up around. These stakes protrude maybe four or five foot out. So they are quite a barrier as well. But Henry decides, you know, he can't afford to let things dangle. So towards the hour of Vespers, so that's, you know, looking, I mean, it's quite late in the day. The sun is setting.
被钉在地上，豌豆在这些木桩周围生长。这些木桩可能突出地面四五英尺。所以它们也是一个相当大的障碍。但亨利决定，你知道，他不能让事情悬而未决。所以接近晚祷时刻，所以那是，你知道，看起来，我的意思是，天色已晚。太阳正在下山。
He decides he has no choice to attack and he cries out in the name of God, take the banners forward. And the Royal Army advances. And the thing that is terrifying for both sides, but perhaps particularly for the Royalists who are having to do the attack, go uphill, they're faced with all these stakes, is the fact that this is the first time that an English army has faced Longbowmen. Yeah. The Cheshire Longbowmen, the best in England. And therefore the world. So you're probably facing the most terrifying military force in the whole of Christendom. And this is clearly a terrifying prospect. Yeah. These are the archers who had
他决定他别无选择只能进攻，他大喊以神之名，带上旗帜前进。皇家军队推进了。对双方来说都非常可怕的事情，但也许特别是对不得不进攻、上坡、面对所有这些木桩的保皇党来说，是这是英格兰军队第一次面对长弓手。是的。柴郡长弓手，英格兰最好的。因此也是世界上最好的。所以你可能面对的是整个基督教世界中最可怕的军事力量。这显然是一个可怕的前景。是的。这些是曾经
wiped out the French at Crecy and Poitiers. Only the year before they'd wiped out the flower of Scottish chivalry at Humbleton Hill. And now the Royalists, Henry IV's army, the Lancastrians are clunking their way up the hill through the peas, past the stakes, and the arrows are just raining down on them. And Thomas Walsingham, this chronicler who we've been drawing on throughout our episodes on this period, key source for the Peasants' Revolt, among other things. He has this very atmospheric description of what happens to Henry's army. Men fell on the king's side as fast as leaves fall in autumn after a hoar frost. So people are just, you know, in the royal line are falling the length of it.
在克雷西和普瓦捷消灭了法国人的弓箭手。就在前一年，他们在亨布尔顿山消灭了苏格兰骑士的精华。现在保皇党，亨利四世的军队，兰开斯特派正在穿过豌豆地，越过木桩，艰难地爬上山坡，箭雨正倾泻在他们身上。托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆，这位我们在这一时期各集中一直引用的编年史家，是农民起义等事件的关键来源。他对亨利军队发生的事情有非常生动的描述。国王一方的人像秋天霜冻后落叶一样纷纷倒下。所以人们只是，你知道，在皇家阵线上，沿着阵线倒下。
And the right side of the royal line buckles, doesn't it? And they begin to break. Yeah, it does. So the king is in the middle. Yeah. The king with his big banner, standard. And Prince Hal, what's happened to him? He's over on the left and a terrible thing happens to him, Tom. Yeah. So he is hit in the face by an arrow. And whether it goes through the slit in his visor or whether he's opened up his visor to try and get a sense of the topography, you know, a helmet on your head. It's kind of very close and oppressive, but either way, the arrow pierces his left cheek just below his eye and it remains embedded in the bone. And amazingly, he doesn't retire from the battle. I mean, I find it hard to believe that he
皇家阵线的右侧崩溃了，不是吗？他们开始溃败。是的，确实。所以国王在中间。是的。国王带着他的大旗，旗帜。哈尔王子，他怎么了？他在左边，一件可怕的事情发生在他身上，汤姆。是的。所以他的脸被一支箭射中了。无论是箭穿过了他面甲的缝隙，还是他为了看清地形打开了面甲，你知道，头上的头盔。它非常紧凑和压抑，但无论如何，箭刺穿了他的左脸颊，就在眼睛下方，并留在了骨头里。令人惊讶的是，他并没有退出战斗。我的意思是，我很难相信他
continues fighting or directing the battle. Although there are chroniclers who say this, but his division and the king's division, they do not collapse and they hold firm. And now increasingly it's Hotspur who has the problem because his archers have begun to run out of arrows. And here is a lesson for the young prince, even though he's got an arrow in his head, Don't run out of arrows. Hotspur's flank also has begun to disintegrate because very Rupert of the Rhine, they followed the fleeing Lancastrians down the hill. And so Hotspur's own line is starting to disintegrate. And they're outnumbered. And the weight of numbers on Henry's side is starting to
继续战斗或指挥战斗。尽管有编年史家这么说，但他的师和国王的师，他们没有崩溃，他们坚守阵地。现在霍特斯珀的问题越来越大，因为他的弓箭手开始用尽箭矢。这对年轻的王子来说是一个教训，即使他的头上插着一支箭，不要用尽箭矢。霍特斯珀的侧翼也开始瓦解，因为非常像莱茵河的鲁珀特，他们跟随逃跑的兰开斯特派跑下山坡。所以霍特斯珀自己的阵线开始瓦解。而且他们人数处于劣势。亨利一方的人数优势开始
bear down. So essentially, Hotspur realizes he's only got one option of victory, and that is to charge and kill the king himself. So that's very Battle of Bosworth, isn't it? Yes, exactly. And so had, you know, we said this in the last episode, had they succeeded in killing Henry IV, then Henry IV's memory would be very much that of a Richard III. So Thomas Walsingham writes, Henry Percy, leader of the opposite army and the Earl of Douglas, the fiery Scott, than whom no one was ever more spirited in spite of the rain of arrows and the dense bodies of horsemen, urged their men against the king's person alone and concentrated all their arms on him.
压下来。所以基本上，霍特斯珀意识到他只有一个胜利的选择，那就是冲锋并亲自杀死国王。所以这非常像博斯沃思战役，不是吗？是的，完全正确。所以，你知道，我们在上一集说过，如果他们成功杀死了亨利四世，那么亨利四世的记忆将非常像理查德三世。所以托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆写道，哈里·珀西，敌军领袖，和道格拉斯伯爵，那个火爆的苏格兰人，除了他之外，没有人比他更有精神，尽管箭雨和密集的骑兵，他们敦促他们的人对抗国王本人，并将所有的武器集中在他身上。
Two problems. There are various people who've been dressed up in the king's surcoat. So it's not immediately clear where Henry IV is. And this is, again, very good in Shakespeare's play. Douglas is rushing around, kind of killing people. Another king, they grow like Hydra's heads. So they're doubles, basically. It's like Vladimir Putin with his doubles. Yes, they're doubles. But also, by doing this, he's pulling people away from the line that had been facing the Prince of Wales division. And that leaves them open to an attack on the flank by the Prince of Wales men. So they kind of crunch into the side of Hotspur's line.
两个问题。有几个人被装扮成国王的罩袍。所以亨利四世在哪里并不立即清楚。这在莎士比亚的戏里也非常好。道格拉斯四处奔波，杀人。另一个国王，他们像九头蛇的头一样生长。所以他们基本上是替身。这就像弗拉基米尔·普京和他的替身。是的，他们是替身。但也因为这样做，他把人们从面对威尔士亲王师的阵线上拉开了。这使他们容易受到威尔士亲王部队的侧翼攻击。所以他们有点撞进了霍特斯珀阵线的侧面。
So now he has no choice but to kill the king because otherwise he's going to be wiped out. And it becomes increasingly clear that Percy and his men are not going to win because Dominic, as dusk gathers and the moon comes out, there is an eclipse and the moon is blotted out. The moon is blotted out. And this is a clear sign that the Percy is going to lose because the Percy livery badge is a crescent moon. I'm sure this definitely happened, Tom. Of course it did. Of course it did. And then in the fighting, Hotspur is killed by whose hand is not known, Walsingham writes.
所以现在他别无选择只能杀死国王，否则他会被消灭。而且越来越清楚的是，珀西和他的手下不会赢，因为多米尼克，随着黄昏降临，月亮出来，发生了日食，月亮被遮住了。月亮被遮住了。这是一个明确的信号，表明珀西要输了，因为珀西的制服徽章是新月。我肯定这绝对发生了，汤姆。当然发生了。当然发生了。然后在战斗中，霍特斯珀被杀，死于谁手不得而知，沃尔辛厄姆写道。
But in Shakespeare, I know from Shakespeare that it was Prince Hal. But actually if Walsingham says, we don't know, it could have been Prince Hal. Well, it couldn't because Prince Hal has a massive great arrow in his head. But you've said that. Now, Edward Hall, who I believe implicitly, says, The Prince Henry that day helped much his father,
但在莎士比亚的作品中，我知道是哈尔王子。但实际上如果沃尔辛厄姆说，我们不知道，那可能是哈尔王子。嗯，不可能，因为哈尔王子的头上插着一支巨大的箭。但你已经说过了。现在，爱德华·霍尔，我隐含地相信他，说，亨利王子那天帮了他父亲很多，
for though he were wounded in the face with an arrow, yet he never ceased either to fight where the battle was most strongest or to courage his men when their hearts were daunted. And I believe Edward Hall implicitly. So you don't believe in eclipses, but you believe that a bloke with an arrow in his skull would be charging around the battlefield. I believe if he is the greatest warrior king in England's history, and he has a history of such conduct, then I absolutely believe it.
因为虽然他的脸被箭射伤，但他从未停止在战斗最激烈的地方战斗，也没有停止在手下心灰意冷时鼓励他们。我隐含地相信爱德华·霍尔。所以你不相信日食，但你相信一个头骨里插着箭的家伙会在战场上冲锋。我相信如果他是英格兰历史上最伟大的战士国王，并且他有这样的行为历史，那么我绝对相信。
Yeah. Well, we will see. We'll come to Henry's wound in a minute. But the level of carnage at Shrewsbury is terrifying. So as we said, this is the first time that rival English armies have been facing Longbowmen and the slaughter is terrible. So maybe 2,000 bodies, perhaps more, are buried in a mass grave. A further 3,000 have suffered terrible wounds, often terminal.
是的。好吧，我们稍后会谈到亨利的伤口。但什鲁斯伯里的杀戮程度是可怕的。所以正如我们所说，这是敌对的英格兰军队第一次面对长弓手，屠杀是可怕的。所以也许2000具尸体，甚至更多，被埋在乱葬坑里。另外3000人遭受了可怕的伤，通常是致命的。
So far more people will die. That's just a regular morning's work in the French Revolution. Well, as in the French Revolution, contemporaries are particularly shocked by how many members of the nobility have been wiped out. Oh dear. You know, that doesn't normally happen. Yeah. Among the nobility who've been killed, of course, is Hotspur himself. So his body is salted to preserve it. And it's then exposed in Shrewsbury marketplace and it's wedged between two millstones and it's then quartered and the various quarters are sent round, you know, the various four reaches of England and his head is chopped off and it's impaled over one of the gates in York. Uh, Worcester is executed and his head is stuck up on London bridge. Douglas, he's already been
所以更多的人会死。那只是法国大革命中一个普通的早晨的工作。嗯，正如在法国大革命中，同时代的人对有多少贵族成员被消灭感到特别震惊。哦，亲爱的。你知道，这通常不会发生。是的。在被杀的贵族中，当然有霍特斯珀本人。所以他的尸体被腌制以保存它。然后它被展示在什鲁斯伯里市场，被楔在两块磨石之间，然后被肢解，各个部分被送到，你知道，英格兰的四个角落，他的头被砍下来，插在约克的城门上。伍斯特被处决，他的头被插在伦敦桥上。道格拉斯，他已经
captured once after falling off his horse and getting an arrow in his eye. And now he falls off his horse again. And this time he crushes one of his testicles, which is very painful. On a rock? Is it on a rock or a stone or something? Yeah. That seems very unfortunate. So he's had a terrible year. But so also, of course, has the poor Prince of Wales. So we have an account of the operation and the wound that he'd suffered from this surgeon who got summoned from London, a man called John Bradmore, who left an account of it. So he said of the wound, he was struck in the face with an arrow beside the nose on the left side, which arrow entered from the side and the head of the said arrow after
在从马上摔下来并眼睛中箭后被俘虏过一次。现在他又从马上摔下来了。这一次他压碎了一个睾丸，这非常痛苦。在石头上？是在石头上还是什么东西上？是的。这看起来非常不幸。所以他度过了糟糕的一年。但当然，可怜的威尔士亲王也是如此。所以我们有关于手术和伤口的记录，来自那个被从伦敦召来的外科医生，一个叫约翰·布拉德莫尔的人，他留下了记录。所以他谈到伤口时说，他被一支箭射中脸部，在左侧鼻子旁边，那支箭从侧面进入，箭镞在箭杆被拔出后，留在了头部骨头的后部，深度达六英寸。是的。所以再次，我向你提出，这使得亨利以如此活力战斗更加令人印象深刻。是的，确实。好的。是的。这是布拉德莫尔关于他如何取出箭的记录。我准备了一些小钳子，小而中空，宽度和箭一样。一根螺丝穿过钳子的中间。我把这些钳子以箭最初进入的角度放入，然后把螺丝放在中心，最后钳子进入了箭镞的插座。然后通过来回移动它，一点一点地，在上帝的帮助下，我取出了箭镞。在取出箭镞后，他显然把治疗药膏按摩进亨利的脖子里。你知道吗，汤姆，我之前对你说过
its shaft was extracted, remained in the back part of the bone of the head to a depth of six inches. Yeah. So again, I put it to you as this makes it all the more impressive that Henry was fighting with such vigor. Yes, it does. Okay. Yeah. And this is Bradmore's account of how he removed the arrow. I prepared in you some little tongs, small and hollow with the width of an arrow. A screw ran through the middle of the tongs. I put these tongs into an angle in the same way as the arrow had first entered, then placed the screw in the center, and finally the tongs entered the socket of the arrowhead. Then by moving it to and fro, little by little, with the help of God, I extracted the arrowhead. And having then extracted the arrowhead, he apparently massages therapeutic ointments into Henry's neck. Do you know, Tom, I said to you before we started
亨利五世让我想起了亚历山大大帝。亚历山大大帝不是侧面中了一箭吗，不是吗？那必须被取出。但不是在他的，我的意思是，不是进入他的头骨。我的意思是，我只是被取出。但不是在他的，我的意思是，不是进入他的头骨。是的。我的意思是，我只是觉得亨利能活下来真是令人震惊。我的意思是，这是一个可怕的伤口。你知道那幅亨利五世的著名画像，他是侧面像？
that Henry V reminds me of Alexander the Great. And didn't Alexander the Great, he had an arrow in his side or something, didn't he? And that had to be removed. But not beneath his, I mean, not into his skull. I mean, I just be removed. But not beneath his, I mean, not into his skull. Yeah. I mean, I just find it astonishing that Henry survives this. I mean, it's an awful wound. And you know the famous painting of Henry V where he's done in profile?
哦，是的，他那荒谬的发型。我有点怀疑伤口是否，我的意思是，留下了未提及的疤痕。我的意思是，那一定很可怕。他会为这样的疤痕感到自豪，汤姆。可怕的伤害。我想他会。任何英国人都会为这样的疤痕感到自豪。
Oh, yeah, with his ridiculous haircuts. I kind of wonder whether the wound was, I mean, left scarring that's not mentioned. I mean, it must have been terrible. He would be proud of such a scar, Tom. Terrible injury. I think he would. And any Englishman would be proud of such a scar.
我的意思是，令人惊奇的是败血症没有发生。是的。他设法挺了过来，但我认为此后他有几个月无法行动。所以让我们回到亨利四世。亨利四世赢得了这场惊人的战斗。是的。他粉碎了霍特斯珀。道格拉斯的睾丸被压碎了。
I mean, what's amazing is that sepsis doesn't sit in. Yeah. He manages to pull through, but I think he's out of action for several months after this. So let's go back to Henry IV. Henry IV has won this amazing battle. Yeah. He has crushed Hotspur. Douglas's testicle has been crushed.
是的。而且他死了。伍斯特，你在戏里扮演的，他的睾丸被压碎了，他死了。伍斯特，你在戏里扮演的，他被刺穿了。嗯，他的头。他的头被刺穿了。但这并没有解决问题，不是吗？因为英格兰人仍然在威尔士横行霸道。所以他那边发生了什么？
Yes. And he's dead. Worcester, who you played in a's testicle has been crushed and he's dead. Worcester, who you played in a play, he has been impaled. Well, his head. His head's been impaled. But this has not settled the issue, has it? Because England are still out there rampaging around Wales. So what's going on with him?
所以什鲁斯伯里是1403年，1404年几乎是格林道尔叛乱、他成功的最高点。所以到1404年，他得到了威尔士各社会阶层和威尔士几乎每个地区的支持。所以1404年，他在马汉莱斯举行了他的第一次议会。你可以去那座建筑。我去过那里，马汉莱斯。非常好。是的。是的。喜欢它。主教们去过那里，马汉莱斯。非常好。
So Shrewsbury is 14-14-03 and 14-04 is pretty much the high watermark of Glendower's rebellion, of his success. So by 1404, he's got the support of the Welsh pretty much across the social classes and from pretty much every part of Wales. So in 1404, he holds his first parliament at Macintyth. You can go to that building. I've been there, Macintyth. Very nice. Yeah. Yeah. Love it. Bishops been there, Mahanthleth. Very nice.
是的。是的。喜欢它。主教们开始倒戈向他，你知道，接受他为国王。是的。而且，你知道，一切对他来说看起来都不错。与此同时，在北方，亨利进军并与诺森伯兰对峙。诺森伯兰来到他面前说，看，我什么都不知道。
Yeah. Yeah. Love it. Bishops are starting to defect to him, you know, accepting him as king. Yeah. And, you know, it's all looking good for him. Meanwhile, in the north, Henry marches up and he's confronting Northumberland. Northumberland comes to him and says, look, I didn't know anything.
我不知道发生了什么。是的，这听起来像个完全的惊喜，我很震惊，我很震惊，亨利决定好吧，如果他这么说，好吧，我选择相信他，并赦免了诺森伯兰，但特别剥夺了诺森伯兰的权力和职位，并将它们交给威斯特摩兰伯爵，作为一种相互制衡的权力。这政治很聪明，不是吗？非常聪明的政治。我的意思是，我认为亨利四世是你那种人，多米尼克。是的。
I had no idea this was going on. Yeah, of likely story came as a total surprise I'm shocked shocked and Henry decides okay if that's what he's saying fine I'll choose to believe him and pardons Northumberland but makes a point of stripping back Northumberland's powers and offices and giving them to the Earl of Westmoreland to be a kind of rival balance of power. That's quite smart politics, isn't it? Very smart politics. I mean, I think Henry IV is your kind of guy, Dominic. Yeah.
你知道，他是一个精明的幸存者。是的。谢谢，汤姆。非常擅长政治艺术。让我们进入你。这非常好。是的，他正是那种我认为你钦佩他的人。我确实钦佩他。我非常钦佩他。我们已经做了大约7000集了。我完全知道你喜欢和钦佩的
You know, he's a shrewd survivor. Yeah. Thanks, Tom. Very adept at the art of politics. Let's get into you. This is very nice. Yeah, he's exactly the kind of man I think you admire him. I do admire him. I admire him a lot. We've done about 7,000 episodes. I know exactly the kind
那种人。所以亨利决定，因为他必须处理威尔士，英格兰仍然在沸腾，苏格兰人在边境，他基本上负担不起除掉诺森伯兰，尽管他显然罪大恶极。1405年，也就是什鲁斯伯里战役两年后，一份重磅文件出炉了。这被历史学家称为《三方契约》。它由欧文·格林道尔发布。根据其条款，英格兰和威尔士将被分为三部分。所以欧文·格林道尔
of people who you like and admire. So Henry has decided that because he's got to deal with Wales, England is still seething, the Scots are on the border, he can't afford basically to take Northumberland out, even though he's clearly guilty as hell. And in 1405, so two years after Shrewsbury, a kind of bombshell document comes out. And this is called the Tripart Indenture by historians. And it's published by Eoghan Glyndwr. And by its terms, England and Wales are to be divided into three. So Eoghan Glyndwr and by its terms England and Wales are to be divided into three. So Eoghan Glyndwr
将得到威尔士和多米尼克你所有的地区。特罗谢普，所有这些。所以所有与威尔士接壤的英格兰郡。哇。所以将会有某种
is to get Wales and Dominic all your region. Trotshep, all that. So all the English counties are butting Wales. Wow. So there'll be a kind of
大威尔士。所以你本来会被培养成一个威尔士人。我是四分之一威尔士人，所以这完全有可能。诺森伯兰将获得北方和中部地区，而将被加冕为国王的埃德蒙·莫蒂默将获得其余部分。即英格兰南部。显然这对亨利四世来说就像一杯冷掉的呕吐物一样难以下咽。现在
greater Wales. So you would have been brought up as a Welshman. I am a quarter Welsh so it's perfectly possible. Northumberland is to receive the North and the Midlands and Edmund Mortimer, who will be crowned King, is to get the rest. So Southern England. And obviously this goes down like a cup of cold sick with Henry IV. Now the
问题是，它是真实的吗？实际上完全没有证据表明诺森伯兰曾去过威尔士谈判。所以我认为共识是这基本上是威尔士的宣传，是英格兰在玩弄黑暗艺术，试图让诺森伯兰对抗亨利。而且它奏效了，因为亨利四世绝对愤怒了。所以他给了威尔士亲王更多的钱，他现在已经从箭伤中恢复了。王子又冲回威尔士，非常成功。他正在夺回威尔士人夺取的据点。他正在实施经济封锁。所以再次，那种理解经济是战争的一部分，是中世纪晚期发动战争的关键部分，正如亨利五世，他将展示出
question is, is it authentic? There's absolutely no evidence at all, actually, of Northumberland having gone down to Wales to negotiate this. So I think the consensus is that it's basically Welsh propaganda, that it's England practicing the dark arts, trying to set Northumberland against Henry. And it works because Henry IV is absolutely furious. So he chucks more money to the Prince of Wales, who's now recovered from his arrow wound. And the Prince kind of piles back into Wales, very successful. He's recapturing strongholds that the Welsh have taken. He's instituting economic blockades. So again, that understanding that economics is a part of warfare, crucial part of waging war in the late Middle Ages, which as Henry V, he will demonstrate an
绝对的掌握。到1407年，格林道尔在威尔士南部和中部的地位正在崩溃。到1409年，王子已经几乎收复了整个公国。同一年，格林道尔的女婿埃德蒙·莫蒂默在战斗中阵亡。格林道尔自己的妻子和两个女儿被俘并被带到塔楼。虽然格林道尔实际上仍然自由，但他现在是一个逃亡者。他正在被追捕。但这是对他所拥有的威尔士情感的致敬，他没有被交出来。他从未被抓住。
absolute mastery of. By 1407, Glyndwr's position in southern and central Wales is crumbling. By 1409, the prince has reconquered pretty much the whole of the principality. And in that same year, Edmund Mortimer, the son-in-law of Glyndwr, is killed in battle. Glyndwr's own wife and two of his daughters are captured and taken to the tower. And though Glyndwr remains at liberty, effectively, he's now a man on the run. He's being hunted down. But it's a tribute to the hold that he has had on Welsh affections that he's not handed over. He's never caught.
我们不知道他何时去世，但他一直处于逃亡状态。与此同时，亨利本人向北进军处理诺森伯兰。他来到约克，在约克，他遭到了一支由一个叫理查德·斯克鲁普的人指挥的约8000人的军队的反对，他令人惊讶地是约克大主教。所以亨利，对此非常生气，与约克大主教谈判。所以亨利，对此非常生气，与约克大主教谈判，达成条款，同意停战。斯克鲁普解散了他的军队。亨利立即逮捕了他，指控他犯有叛国罪。大主教被判犯有叛国罪。他被拖到田野里斩首。所以就是这样。再次，我想象那是你赞同的那种对麻烦教士的强硬态度，不是吗？
We don't know when he dies, but he remains on the run for good. Meanwhile, Henry himself has marched north to deal with Northumberland. He comes to York and at York, he's opposed by an army of some 8,000 men commanded by a guy called Richard Scroope, who is amazingly the Archbishop of York. So Henry, very cross about this, negotiates with the Archbishop of York. So Henry, very cross about this, negotiates with the Archbishop of York, agrees terms, agrees to a truce. Scrooge stands down his army. Henry promptly arrests him, has him charged with high treason. The Archbishop is convicted of high treason. He's dragged out into a field and beheaded. So that is that. And again, I imagine that that's the kind of robust approach to troublesome clerics that you give thumbs up to, wouldn't you?
我会的。如你所知，我曾经扮演过托马斯·贝克特，在《苏格兰人报》上得到了非常令人不快的评论。但我非常熟悉麻烦教士的工作，我认为你只需要强硬，汤姆。而且，你知道吗？亨利四世和亨利五世，他们很棒。我喜欢亨利四世和亨利五世，因为我钦佩擅长政治的人。他们真的很棒。他们赢了。亨利四世有一个可怕的遗产。他领先了。亨利五世，如果你看亨利五世在威尔士，例如，那场战役对他来说可能出了大问题。
I would. I once played Thomas Beckett, as you know, got a very displeasing review in The Scotsman. But I'm very familiar with the work of troublesome clerics, and I think you just have to be tough, Tom. And actually, do you know what? Henry IV and Henry V, they're brilliant. I love Henry IV and Henry V because I admire people who are good at politics. They're really good. They win. Henry IV has a horrendous inheritance. He comes out ahead. Henry V, if you look at Henry V in Wales, for example, that campaign could have gone horribly wrong for him.
他可能被伏击或什么的。但实际上，他打出了他的牌。他挺过来了。是的。这有点——多米尼克，只是为了强调。是的。我的意思是，亨利四世已经有了几个污点，他是一个篡位者和一个弑君者。
He could have been ambushed or whatever. But actually, he plays his hand. He pulls through. Yeah. It's kind of the- Dominic, just to emphasize. Yeah. I mean, Henry IV has already had a couple of black marks that he's a usurper and a regicide.
他本可能遭到伏击或遭遇其他不测。但实际上，他打出了自己的底牌。他挺过来了。是的。这有点……多米尼克，强调一下。是的。我的意思是，亨利四世已经有了几个污点，因为他是一个篡位者和弑君者。
But he's now a man who has killed an archbishop. Who cares? And the paradox, of course, is that he's actually a very, very devout man. Not the kind of man that you would say would be the first English king to put an archbishop to death. But it is what it is. Yeah, he did it and he was quite right to do it. Well, or was he? Because it's possible that it has a devastating effect,
但他现在是一个杀害了大主教的人。谁在乎呢？当然，矛盾之处在于，他实际上是一个非常、非常虔诚的人。你绝不会说他是那种会成为第一个处死大主教的英国国王。但事实就是这样。是的，他确实这么做了，而且他认为自己做得完全正确。嗯，真的是这样吗？因为这可能会产生毁灭性的影响，
that the wrath of God is visited on him. And I think we'll find out whether that's true or not. After the break. After the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
上帝的愤怒降临在他身上。我想我们会在休息之后找出答案。休息之后。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即一切》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
以及一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Can honour set to a leg? No. Or an arm? No. Or take away the grief to a leg? No. Or an arm? No. Or take away the grief of a wound? No. Honour hath no skill in surgery, then? No. What is honour? A word. What is in that word? Honour.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。荣誉能接好一条腿吗？不能。或者一只胳膊？不能。或者消除伤口的痛苦吗？不能。那么荣誉就没有外科手术的技能了？没有。什么是荣誉？一个词。那个词里有什么？荣誉。
What is that honour? Air. A trim reckoning. Who hath it? He that died on Wednesday. Doth he feel it? No. Doth he hear it? No. Tis insensible then, yea, to the dead. But will it not live with the living? No. Why? Detraction will not suffer it. Ah, therefore I'll none of it. Honor is a mere scutcheon. And so ends my catechism. So that's Sir John Falstaff. In fact, the critic Harold Bloom, he was Shakespeare's greatest character, the character who invented what it was to be human.
那荣誉是什么？空气。一个虚浮的算计。谁拥有它？那个周三死去的人。他能感觉到吗？不能。他能听到吗？不能。那么它对死者来说是无感的。但它不会与生者同在吗？不会。为什么？诽谤不会容忍它。啊，所以我一点也不要它。荣誉不过是一个盾徽。我的教义问答到此结束。这就是约翰·法斯塔夫爵士。事实上，评论家哈罗德·布鲁姆认为，他是莎士比亚最伟大的角色，是那个发明了何为人性的角色。
Don't you agree? I mean, I really think he is. I do agree. Yeah. I think he's brilliant. That speech, he gives that speech at the Battle of Shrewsbury. He is a total coward.
你不觉得吗？我是说，我真的认为他是。我同意。是的。我觉得他太棒了。那段演讲，他在什鲁斯伯里战役中发表的那段演讲。他是个彻头彻尾的懦夫。
He's a ridiculous figure, a fat man, total coward, very Billy Bunter, crossed with Flashman. He lies down, pretends to be dead, and then after the battle, he kind of jumps up and he says, oh, and I killed Hotspur. And it's a very amusing scene. And actually, it's a brilliant speech because very unusually, for a dramatist of his period, Shakespeare is giving Falstaff lines with which a lot of the audience would probably deep down agree
他是一个荒谬的人物，一个胖子，彻头彻尾的懦夫，非常像比利·邦特与弗莱什曼的结合体。他躺下假装死亡，然后在战斗结束后，他跳起来说，哦，我杀了霍茨珀。这是一个非常有趣的场景。实际上，这是一段精彩的演讲，因为莎士比亚非常罕见地（对于他那个时代的剧作家而言）给了法斯塔夫一些台词，很多观众在内心深处可能会同意这些台词，
that all the talk of honour that Henry V so supremely embodies is actually just hot air. What is honour? Air, a trim reckoning. Who hath it? He that died on Wednesday. You know, that it actually counts for nothing. I mean, that's an extraordinary thing for Shakespeare to have written, I always think. Yeah. And the genius of it is that in Henry IV plays, this has an appeal for Prince Hal, the man who will grow up to become Henry V. It's seductive. In a way, Falstaff is mocking everything that Henry V will become.
即亨利五世所极力体现的所有关于荣誉的言论，实际上都只是空谈。什么是荣誉？空气，一个虚浮的算计。谁拥有它？那个周三死去的人。你知道，这实际上毫无价值。我是说，我一直认为，这对莎士比亚来说是一个非凡的创作。是的。而它的天才之处在于，在《亨利四世》剧中，这对哈尔王子——那个长大后将成为亨利五世的人——具有吸引力。它是诱人的。在某种程度上，法斯塔夫是在嘲弄亨利五世将要成为的一切。
He is mocking the idea of glory, of honor, of military achievement. He's scorning chivalric and military ideals. And it is incredibly funny. But it is also, I think, I mean, I don't think the audience is meant just to identify with Falstaff. No, no, no. Falstaff himself, he's a thief. He's a liar. He's a man who deliberately recruits people who are not qualified to fight and who will therefore die and pockets the money.
他嘲弄荣耀、荣誉、军事成就的概念。他蔑视骑士精神和军事理想。这非常有趣。但我认为，我不认为观众只是被要求认同法斯塔夫。不，不，不。法斯塔夫本人，他是个小偷。他是个骗子。他是一个故意招募没有战斗资格的人，从而让他们去送死，并把钱装进自己口袋的人。
So in a way, he famously becomes the symbol of everything that Prince Hal has to reject to become Henry V. So there's this famous line where Falstaff is talking to Prince Hal and he says, for sweet Jack Falstaff, kind Jack Falstaff, true Jack Falstaff, valiant Jack Falstaff, and therefore more valiant being as he is old Jack Falstaff, banish not him thy Harry's company, banish not him thy Harryry's company banish plump jack and banish all the world and prince how famously says to himself i do i will the thing there is that uh full staff is pretending to be henry the fourth and he's sat on the the throne isn't he with the sort of crown on
所以从某种意义上说，他成为了哈尔王子为了成为亨利五世而必须拒绝的一切的象征。所以有一句名言，法斯塔夫对哈尔王子说，为了亲爱的杰克·法斯塔夫，善良的杰克·法斯塔夫，真实的杰克·法斯塔夫，英勇的杰克·法斯塔夫，因此作为老杰克·法斯塔夫更加英勇，不要把你哈里的伙伴放逐，不要把你哈里的伙伴放逐，放逐了胖杰克就等于放逐了全世界，而哈尔王子对他自己说了一句名言，我做，我会的。那个场景是，呃，法斯塔夫假装是亨利四世，他坐在王位上，对吧，戴着某种王冠。
yeah and prince how is playing himself talking to his father yeah and again for people who've never seen hen IV plays, we recommended Chimes at Midnight with Orson Welles as Falstaff. The role he was born to play, and this is brilliantly done in that film. So do check that out if you haven't seen it. So the other thing, of course, about Falstaff
是的，哈尔王子扮演他自己，在和他的父亲说话。是的，同样，对于那些从未看过《亨利四世》剧的人，我们推荐奥逊·威尔斯饰演法斯塔夫的《午夜钟声》。那是他天生要扮演的角色，在这部电影中表现得非常出色。所以如果你还没看过，一定要去看看。所以，关于法斯塔夫的另一件事，当然是
is he never actually existed. Right. So, I mean, in a way, you know, the question is, where does he come from? And basically he comes from Shakespeare's imagination. And perhaps that's why he is, I think, in a way, you know, the question is, where does he come from? And basically he comes from Shakespeare's imagination. And perhaps that's why he is, I think, Bloom is absolutely right, Shakespeare's greatest creation. But he doesn't come entirely from Shakespeare's imagination because there are roots to Falstaff. So let's, in the second half, talk about the one character who is emblematic of the reign of Henry IV,
他从未真正存在过。对。所以，我的意思是，在某种程度上，你知道，问题是，他从哪里来？基本上他来自莎士比亚的想象力。也许这就是为什么他，我认为，在某种程度上，你知道，问题是，他从哪里来？基本上他来自莎士比亚的想象力。也许这就是为什么他，我认为，布鲁姆绝对是对的，他是莎士比亚最伟大的创造。但他并不完全来自莎士比亚的想象力，因为法斯塔夫是有根源的。所以，让我们在下半场谈谈那个象征着亨利四世统治的人物，
who you say didn't exist, John Falstaff. Yeah, he didn't exist. There was somebody called John Fastolf, wasn't there? Yes. Later on, he features fighting against Joan of Arc and he did become a byword for cowardice because he was accused of running away at a battle in the late 1420s. Yeah, unfairly. So he seems the obvious antecedent to Shakespeare's Falstaff. Yeah. So he does get accused of cowardice. He complains about this. He demands basically a kind of an inquiry and the inquiry does exonerate him. But you know, the taint lingers. Fastoff then goes off to East Anglia where he amuses himself in his old age by
你说他不存在，约翰·法斯塔夫。是的，他不存在。有一个叫约翰·法斯托夫的人，对吧？是的。后来，他以与圣女贞德作战而闻名，并因在1420年代末的一场战斗中被指控逃跑而成为懦弱的代名词。是的，不公平地。所以他似乎是莎士比亚法斯塔夫显而易见的先驱。是的。所以他确实被指控懦弱。他对此抱怨。他基本上要求进行某种调查，调查确实还了他清白。但你知道，污点依然存在。法斯托夫后来去了东安格利亚，在那里他晚年以
engaging in rows over property with the Pastons. The most famous letters of the 15th century. The character of Sir John Falstaff, and clearly the name John Falstaff comes from this guy, John Fastolf. But in the original version of the play, he was called Sir John Oldcastle. And Shakespeare only changes that name after getting pressured by one of Oldcastle's descendants, who's a figure of some power. And so the question is, who was Sir John Oldcastle? And Sir John Oldcastle, the historical John Oldcastle, was indeed a friend of the Prince of Wales, of Prince Hal, as Shakespeare portrays him. But he was not a coward. He was a very proficient soldier who had fought in Wales alongside the prince and become a
与帕斯顿家族争夺财产为乐。这是15世纪最著名的信件。约翰·法斯塔夫爵士这个角色，显然约翰·法斯塔夫这个名字来自这个人，约翰·法斯托夫。但在剧本的原始版本中，他被称为约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士。莎士比亚只是在受到奥尔卡斯尔的一位后裔（一个有权势的人物）的压力后才更改了那个名字。所以问题是，谁是约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士？约翰·奥尔卡斯尔，历史上的约翰·奥尔卡斯尔，确实是威尔士亲王、哈尔王子的朋友，正如莎士比亚所描绘的那样。但他不是懦夫。他是一位非常有能力的士兵，曾与王子一起在威尔士作战，并成为
very close companion in arms to the prince. But in Shakespeare's play, when Prince Hal becomes Henry V, he banishes Jack Falstaff. He rejects him. Tragic scene. I know thee not, old man. Yeah, terrible. And he goes off, you know, he leaves the taverns behind and he goes off to conquer France. The historical John Oldcastle is also spectacularly repudiated by the prince after he becomes Henry V. So John Oldcastle ends up being imprisoned in the tower.
王子非常亲密的战友。但在莎士比亚的剧中，当哈尔王子成为亨利五世时，他放逐了杰克·法斯塔夫。他拒绝了他。悲剧性的场景。我不认识你，老头。是的，太可怕了。他离开了，你知道，他把酒馆抛在身后，去征服法国。历史上的约翰·奥尔卡斯尔在成为亨利五世后，也受到了王子的严厉谴责。所以约翰·奥尔卡斯尔最终被关进了伦敦塔。
He then escapes it. He ferments a rebellion against Henry V. He escapes into the badlands of the Welsh Marches, Dominic, your neck of the woods. He gets captured. He gets brought back to London. He gets brought to just off Charing Cross Road, just by Foyle's bookshop. They put up a scaffold and they light a fire underneath it. And Sir John Oldcastle is hanged while simultaneously being burnt. So, I mean, none of this goes into Henry V. You may wonder what has Sir John Oldcastle does. And there is a clue in Henry IV part two, because
他后来逃脱了。他煽动了针对亨利五世的叛乱。他逃到了威尔士边境的荒野，多米尼克，那是你的地盘。他被抓住了。他被带回伦敦。他被带到查令十字路口附近，就在福伊尔书店旁边。他们竖起了一个脚手架，并在下面点了一把火。约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士在被烧死的同时被绞死。所以，我的意思是，这些都没有进入《亨利五世》。你可能想知道约翰·奥尔卡斯尔做了什么。在《亨利四世》第二部中有一个线索，因为
Shakespeare in an epilogue, he talks about Falstaff and he says that, you know, in the sequel, which will be about the reign of Henry V, Falstaff shall die of a sweat Like a fever. And then he adds, for Oldcastle died a martyr, and this is not the man. Shakespeare is saying, this guy isn't Sir John Oldcastle because Oldcastle died a martyr. And why did Oldcastle die a martyr? The reason is that he was seen by Shakespeare's contemporaries as being a proto-Protestant. Sir John Oldcastle, Dominic, was a Lollard. So the Lollards. Let's talk about the Lollards a bit.
莎士比亚在尾声中谈到了法斯塔夫，他说，你知道，在续集中，也就是关于亨利五世统治的续集里，法斯塔夫将死于一种汗热病，就像发烧一样。然后他补充说，因为奥尔卡斯尔死于殉道，而这并不是那个人。莎士比亚是在说，这个人不是约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士，因为奥尔卡斯尔死于殉道。为什么奥尔卡斯尔死于殉道？原因是他被莎士比亚的同时代人视为原始新教徒。约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士，多米尼克，是一个罗拉德派教徒。所以罗拉德派。让我们谈谈罗拉德派。
We have mentioned them before. They turned up in the Peasants' Revolt. Historians still argue about the Lollards. Did they exist or were they a little bit like the Cathars, a kind of invention of the authorities who conflated a lot of dissenters or marginalised heretics? But you think they did exist? Well, I do because they're also called Wycliffeites. And they take that name because
我们之前提到过他们。他们出现在农民起义中。历史学家仍然在争论罗拉德派。他们真的存在吗？还是他们有点像卡特里派，是当局为了合并许多异见者或边缘化的异端而发明的一种东西？但你认为他们确实存在？嗯，我确实这么认为，因为他们也被称为威克里夫派。他们取这个名字是因为
they are inspired by the teaching of a man who definitely existed, who was an Oxford scholar called John Wycliffe, who'd been dismissed from the university in 1381 for heresy. A Balliol man like Rory Stewart and Ted Heath. A Balliol man. And he preached a kind of very radical, again, proto-Protestant kind of anti-clericalism. He denied the authority of the Pope. He demanded that the church be stripped of its property and possessions. So that was something that had obviously appealed to the rebels in the Great Revolt. Very hostile to icons, to pilgrimages, to clerical celibacy. He doesn't believe in purgatory. So again, a presaging of
他们受到一个确实存在的人的教导的启发，那是一个名叫约翰·威克里夫的牛津学者，他在1381年因异端邪说被大学开除。一个像罗里·斯图尔特和泰德·希思一样的贝利奥尔学院的人。一个贝利奥尔学院的人。他宣扬了一种非常激进的、同样是原始新教式的反教权主义。他否认教皇的权威。他要求剥夺教会的财产和所有物。所以这显然是吸引了伟大起义中叛军的东西。非常敌视偶像、朝圣、教士独身制。他不相信炼狱。所以，这再次预示了
the Reformation. And also a presaging of the Reformation at its most radical, there's a denial of the fact that the bread and wine of the Eucharist are turned literally into the body and the blood of Christ. And the reason for this, as in the protestant reformation is a sense that it's not the church but the bible yeah that should be the kind of the great central driving force in their lives and there'd been a decades-long campaign against them you know this is why wickliffe gets um kicked out of oxford gets dismissed yeah there's a kind of ongoing campaign to try and extirpate this this heresy but henry the fourth's reign sees a kind of ongoing campaign to try and extirpate this heresy. But Henry IV's reign sees a kind of escalating campaign. So in 1401, a chaplain called William Sautry is burned for
宗教改革。而且也预示了最激进的宗教改革，即否认圣餐中的面包和酒字面上变成了基督的身体和血的事实。而这背后的原因，正如在新教改革中一样，是一种感觉，即不是教会，而是圣经，是的，那应该是他们生活中伟大的核心驱动力。而且几十年来一直有一场针对他们的运动，你知道，这就是为什么威克里夫被赶出牛津，被开除，是的，有一场持续的运动试图根除这种异端，但亨利四世的统治见证了一场持续的运动试图根除这种异端。但亨利四世的统治见证了一场不断升级的运动。所以1401年，一个名叫威廉·索特里的牧师因为
his views on the Eucharist, his denial of the fact of the real presence of Christ in the bread and wine. And he's the first heretic to be burned in England for 70 years. And this is really being pushed by Parliament. So eight days after this guy is burned, they pass a statute that they call for the burning of a heretic, which essentially licenses the royal authorities to target the Lollards more fully. Okay, so why is there this crackdown?
他对圣餐的看法，他对基督在面包和酒中真实存在的事实的否认，而被烧死。他是70年来英国第一个被烧死的异端。这实际上是由议会推动的。所以在这个人被烧死八天后，他们通过了一项法令，他们呼吁烧死异端，这本质上授权皇家当局更全面地针对罗拉德派。好吧，那么为什么要进行这种镇压？
Is it because this proto-Protestantism in a time of great political turmoil, you know, high political turmoil, is gathered strength because authority is maybe under question or is broken down in some way? I mean, we're not that long after the Black Death, by the way, or the Peasants' Revolt. Or is it because there's a new mood of intolerance towards stuff that previously might have just gone unpunished? I think it's partly because Parliament is in a position to require Henry to take steps that they want to. And there's a lot of opposition to the Lollards in Parliament. But I think it's also because there's been an incredible outbreak of heresy in Bohemia. The Hussites, and Jan Hus, who in our episode on Luther, we talked about
是因为这种原始新教在政治动荡时期，你知道，高度政治动荡时期，因为权威可能受到质疑或以某种方式崩溃而聚集了力量吗？我的意思是，顺便说一句，我们距离黑死病或农民起义并没有过去太久。还是因为有一种新的不宽容情绪，针对那些以前可能未受惩罚的事情？我认为部分原因是议会有能力要求亨利采取他们想要的措施。议会中有很多反对罗拉德派的声音。但我认为这也是因为波希米亚爆发了令人难以置信的异端邪说。胡斯派，以及扬·胡斯，在我们的路德剧集中，我们谈到了
again as a kind of a precursor of Protestantism. And Huss had been very, very strongly influenced by Wycliffe. So I think there's an incredible anxiety as the Hussite rebellion starts kind of kicking off. There's a big anxiety that this might happen in England. But having said that, it's not like there's a sudden great wave of burnings. So the next person to be burned in England for lullaby, it's not for nine years. And it's a tailor from Evesham called John Bradby, who's condemned for declaring that the Eucharist is of less value than a spider, since a spider is a living creature. And he says this in his trial and it's recorded in the transcript of the trial that as he says this, a large black spider appears on the heretics lips. Um, and,
再次作为新教的前身。胡斯深受威克里夫的影响。所以我认为随着胡斯叛乱开始爆发，有一种令人难以置信的焦虑。人们非常担心这可能会在英国发生。但话虽如此，并不是说突然出现了一大波烧死人的浪潮。所以英国下一个因罗拉德派而被烧死的人，九年内都没有。那是一个名叫约翰·布拉德比的伊夫舍姆裁缝，他因宣称圣餐的价值低于蜘蛛（因为蜘蛛是活的生物）而被定罪。他在审判中说了这句话，审判记录中记载，当他说这句话时，一只巨大的黑蜘蛛出现在异端的嘴唇上。嗯，而且，
uh, Bradley tries to wipe it away and the spider scuttles over his face and then vanishes down his mouth by alien. So that definitely happened. I mean, that's definitely, well, I, well, it was convincing enough that the poor guy gets handed over to the secular authorities and he gets taken to Smithfield, uh, you know, outside the city of London and he gets chained to, um, to a stake, great heap of faggots piled up around him. And he gets ringed by a great throng of people that includes the Prince, Prince Henry. And the pyre gets lit and the flames start kind of licking and heading towards this poor guy who's chained to the stake. And he cries out and the prince thinks maybe he wants to recant.
布拉德比试图把它擦掉，蜘蛛爬过他的脸，然后消失在他的嘴里。所以那绝对发生了。我的意思是，那绝对是，嗯，我，嗯，它足够令人信服，以至于这个可怜的家伙被移交给了世俗当局，他被带到了史密斯菲尔德，呃，你知道，伦敦城外，他被锁在，嗯，一根柱子上，周围堆着一大堆柴火。他被一大群人包围，其中包括王子，亨利王子。柴堆被点燃，火焰开始舔舐并向这个被锁在柱子上的可怜家伙蔓延。他大声呼喊，王子以为他可能想忏悔。
And so he orders the flames to be put out and he offers this poor tailor, I'll give you a life pension of three pence a day if you'll recant. Good offer. And the tailor refuses. Mad. So he gets burned, turned to ashes. And the prince watches it. And people may be wondering, well, why is the prince attending this execution?
于是他下令扑灭火焰，并向这个可怜的裁缝提出，如果你忏悔，我每天给你三便士的终身养老金。很好的提议。但裁缝拒绝了。疯了。所以他被烧成了灰烬。王子看着这一切。人们可能想知道，好吧，为什么王子要参加这次处决？
And I think undoubtedly it's to signal his backing for the measures taken by the church. But what about his kind of personal take on this? And I think there are two possible alternatives that would explain that. The first is that he is a committed persecutor of Lollards. Henry is very devout, very orthodox. In 1415, by which time he's become, of course, Henry V, it's the year of Agincourt. There's a Frenchman who says, this king looks more like a priest than a warrior. And he's named by the Lollards, the priest's king. So there's a Frenchman who says this king looks more like a priest than a warrior. And he's named by the Lollards the priest's king. So there's a sense that he is perhaps more committed to the campaign against Lollardy
我认为毫无疑问，这是为了表明他支持教会采取的措施。但关于他对此的个人看法呢？我认为有两种可能的选择可以解释这一点。第一种是他是罗拉德派的坚定迫害者。亨利非常虔诚，非常正统。1415年，那时他当然已经成为亨利五世，那是阿金库尔战役的一年。有一个法国人说，这位国王看起来更像个牧师而不是战士。他被罗拉德派称为牧师国王。所以有一种感觉，他可能比他的父亲更致力于反对罗拉德派的运动。
than his father. Some of the academics who've written about Henry V recently have really played that up. The fact that he is really, really pious. Yeah, he is. And is absolutely committed to religious orthodoxy in a way that a lot of other medieval kings, maybe they mildly cared, but they didn't care that much. Whereas he is, there's some austerity about him in the fifth, isn't there? There's kind of moral austerity to him.
最近写过亨利五世的一些学者确实强调了这一点。他非常、非常虔诚的事实。是的，他是。而且他绝对致力于宗教正统，这与许多其他中世纪国王不同，也许他们稍微关心一点，但他们并不那么关心。而他，他身上有一种苦行，不是吗？他身上有一种道德上的苦行。
There is, but there's also something perhaps that Shakespeare was in the end making play with a sense that before he became king, perhaps his attitudes to it was more complicated. Because remember, Sir John Oldcastle, who is the most notorious Lollard of his age, this is a guy who ends up leading a kind of Lollard rebellion against Henry V. I mean, he's not just mildly Lollard. He's full blown. His last words before he gets burned are a prophecy that he's going to rise on the third day. So, I mean, he's all in as a heretic. And so it is kind of weird that this very devout, this very orthodox prince should be friends with such a man. And what sharpens the sense of mystery is that the House of Lancaster historically had actually had a record of sympathizing with Wycliffe's teachings.
确实有，但也许莎士比亚最终也在玩弄一种感觉，即在他成为国王之前，也许他对它的态度更复杂。因为记住，约翰·奥尔卡斯尔爵士，他是他那个时代最臭名昭著的罗拉德派，这家伙最终领导了一场针对亨利五世的罗拉德派叛乱。我的意思是，他不仅仅是轻微的罗拉德派。他是彻头彻尾的。他在被烧死前的遗言是一个预言，说他将在第三天复活。所以，我的意思是，他作为一个异端是全心全意的。所以这个非常虔诚、非常正统的王子竟然和这样一个人是朋友，这确实有点奇怪。而让这种神秘感加剧的是，兰开斯特家族在历史上实际上有同情威克里夫教义的记录。
So people who listened to our episode on the Peasants' Revolt may remember that we talked about how John of Gaunt, Henry V's grandfather, had been Wycliffe's patron and Henry IV's confessor, a guy called Philip Reppingdon. So the person who Henry IV is turning to in his deepest hours of need, his moments of particular spiritual anguish, he'd been a follower of Wycliffe, even though he'd recanted this. Nevertheless, he's very familiar with Wycliffe's theology and teachings. And it's evident that in the previous episode said Henry is questioning as a Christian. He's not a passive Christian. He's interested in all kinds of doctrine and theology and spiritual practice. He owns a copy of the Bible in English, for instance. He stands up for academic freedom in Oxford. He's very committed to the idea that the church needs reform. In his own personal life, he's committed to the kind of simplicity of behavior
所以听过我们关于农民起义那一集的人可能还记得，我们谈到亨利五世的祖父冈特的约翰曾是威克里夫的赞助人，而亨利四世的忏悔神父，一个叫菲利普·雷平顿的人。所以亨利四世在他最需要的时候，在他精神极度痛苦的时刻求助的人，曾是威克里夫的追随者，尽管他后来忏悔了。尽管如此，他非常熟悉威克里夫的神学和教义。显而易见，在上一集中说亨利作为一个基督徒是在质疑的。他不是一个被动的基督徒。他对各种教义、神学和精神实践都很感兴趣。例如，他拥有一本英文圣经。他支持牛津的学术自由。他非常致力于教会需要改革的想法。在他个人的生活中，他致力于那种行为上的简单，
that is typical of, if you like, soft loladi. So I just wonder whether there's a hint in the prince's friendship with old castle of how it ultimately comes to be interpreted as being a kind of king who on ascending the throne repents of something that he feels a bit embarrassed about, a bit ashamed about and banishes, you know, all his former companions. That totally psychologically would make sense that he had flirted with this stuff maybe, or he'd been... I don't think he'd ever... Not flirted, that's the wrong way. He'd been curious about it maybe. He'd been soft on someone who was... Yeah, it's Keir Starmer and Jeremy Corbyn. I know thee not, old man.
这如果是的话，是典型的温和罗拉德派。所以我只是想知道，在王子与奥尔卡斯尔的友谊中，是否暗示了他最终如何被解读为一种国王，即在登上王位后，对自己感到有点尴尬、有点羞愧的事情表示忏悔，并放逐了，你知道，他所有的前同伴。这在心理上完全说得通，他可能曾涉足这些东西，或者他曾……我不认为他曾经……不是涉足，那是错误的说法。他可能对它感到好奇。他对某个人很宽容……是的，那是基尔·斯塔默和杰里米·科尔宾。我不认识你，老头。
Yeah. That's exactly what it is, Tom. Yeah. But if so, I think that's not the only explanation for the full staff story and everything and the idea that Henry V had been a great enthusiast for riot as a young man. Because there's also a clue, I think, in another very famous story that is told about him as the Prince of Wales,
是的。汤姆，那正是它的含义。是的。但如果是这样，我认为这并不是法斯塔夫故事的唯一解释，也不是亨利五世年轻时曾是暴乱狂热爱好者的想法的唯一解释。因为我认为，关于他作为威尔士亲王时所讲述的另一个非常著名的故事中也有一个线索，
which happens just before Henry IV dies. So the 20th of March in 1413, Henry IV is on his deathbed, and he's lying in bed bed and beside him on a pillow is the crown and the prince is outside and the king's attendants think that henry has breathed his last and so they go out and they tell the prince you know you are now the king you are now henry the fifth and so he goes in and he sees the crown and he picks it up puts it on his head kind of wanders off to go and start being a king and then it turns out Henry IV isn't dead and he kind of sits up and says where's the crown and he's told oh the prince of Wales has gone off with it and
这发生在亨利四世去世前不久。所以1413年3月20日，亨利四世在临终床上，他躺在床上，枕头旁边是王冠，王子在外面，国王的侍从认为亨利已经咽了最后一口气，于是他们走出去告诉王子，你知道，你现在是国王了，你现在是亨利五世了，于是他走进去，看到了王冠，他把它拿起来戴在头上，有点漫不经心地去开始当国王，然后结果亨利四世并没有死，他坐起来说，王冠在哪里？有人告诉他，哦，威尔士亲王把它拿走了，而且
he's furious and he summons the prince back and the king says to him and how my son do you have any right to it for as you well know I never had any and the prince answers him you held it with your sword my lord and for as long as i live i shall do the same and the king replies very well then the rest i leave to god and i pray him to have mercy on me and these are his last words and then he he dies now this is a story that is told about 20 years after the events it purports to describe it also smacks of the kind of story that is told about 20 years after the events it purports to describe. It also smacks of the kind of story that is told about kings in all cultures. It's a great story, though. So Christopher Ormond, who's written a brilliant biography of Henry V, I mean, he says of this
他非常愤怒，他召回了王子，国王对他说，哈尔，我的儿子，你有什么权利拥有它吗？因为正如你很清楚的那样，我从来没有拥有过。王子回答他，你用你的剑守住了它，我的主，只要我活着，我就要这样做。国王回答说，好吧，那么剩下的我留给上帝，我祈求他怜悯我。这些是他最后的遗言，然后他去世了。现在，这是一个在事件发生约20年后才讲述的故事，它也带有那种在事件发生约20年后才讲述的故事的味道。它也带有那种在所有文化中关于国王的故事的味道。不过，这是一个伟大的故事。所以克里斯托弗·奥蒙德，他写了一本关于亨利五世的精彩传记，我的意思是，他谈到这个
story, there's never smoke without fire. That's, I mean, for an academic, that is the most shocking line. Oh, well, there's no smoke without fire. It probably happened. I mean, come on. You know, this is a great scholar, Dominic. Let's not diss him. What this story draws attention to is that actually in the final years of Henry IV's reign,
故事时说，无风不起浪。我的意思是，对于一个学者来说，那是令人震惊的一句话。哦，好吧，无风不起浪。它可能发生了。我的意思是，得了吧。你知道，这是一个伟大的学者，多米尼克。我们不要贬低他。这个故事引起人们注意的是，实际上在亨利四世统治的最后几年，
he is a very sick man. And he'd been a sick man long before his death. And you were a great enthusiast for murdering archbishops, chopping their heads off. I'm all over it. But contemporaries blamed this illness of Henry IV on his crime in beheading an archbishop. I'm going to tell you now, that's not how illnesses work. Dominic, it is. They were mistaken. It is, because on the 8th of June, 1405, which is the very day that the archbishop has been put to death, Henry IV rides out of York. He's heading up north to go and sort out Northumberland.
他是一个非常虚弱的人。他在去世前很久就是一个虚弱的人了。而你是一个谋杀大主教、砍下他们脑袋的狂热爱好者。我完全赞同。但同时代的人将亨利四世的这种疾病归咎于他斩首大主教的罪行。我现在要告诉你，疾病不是那样运作的。多米尼克，它是。他们错了。它是，因为1405年6月8日，也就是大主教被处决的那一天，亨利四世骑马离开了约克。他正前往北方去解决诺森伯兰的问题。
The wind starts screaming, clearly the marker of the anger of God. Rain starts scudding in. And so Henry diverts. He goes off to a manor, the manor of Greenhamerton, and he's put up in the best bed in Greenhamerton. They light a fire. He goes to sleep. And then in the middle of the night, he starts screaming, Traitor! Traitors! You have thrown fire over me! And his servants come running, and they find that he's absolutely, you know, his face is burning up. His skin is full of pustules. And from this point on, he is incredibly sick.
风开始尖叫，显然是上帝愤怒的标志。雨开始倾盆而下。于是亨利改道了。他去了格林哈默顿庄园，他被安置在格林哈默顿最好的床上。他们点了一把火。他睡着了。然后在半夜，他开始尖叫，叛徒！叛徒！你们把火扔在我身上！他的仆人跑过来，发现他绝对是，你知道，他的脸在燃烧。他的皮肤上长满了脓疱。从这一点开始，他变得非常虚弱。
So what do you say to that? I don't know. I mean, it's obviously just total gibberish and tosh, isn't it? That's absolutely not. I mean, I can well believe, because he does have this disease that keeps recurring, right? A skin disease. Yeah. So Adam of Usk, our old friend, the Welsh prince, says it's a festering of the flesh and dehydration of the eyes. And if that's not a punishment sent by the Almighty, I don't know what is. I think people do have festerings of the flesh who have not executed archbishops. I mean,
那么你对此有什么看法？我不知道。我的意思是，这显然完全是胡言乱语和废话，不是吗？那绝对不是。我的意思是，我可以相信，因为他确实患有这种反复发作的疾病，对吧？一种皮肤病。是的。所以亚当·奥斯克，我们的老朋友，那位威尔士亲王，说那是肉体的溃烂和眼睛的脱水。如果那不是全能者降下的惩罚，我就不知道什么是了。我认为人们确实有肉体溃烂，但他们并没有处决大主教。我的意思是，
that to me seems like a giveaway, right of people in the french revolution right mirabeau mara um pretty much all the characters we discussed actually had faces like craters of pustules none of them had executed archbishops or not yet executed archbishops anyway yeah so so listeners can decide so contemporaries say that it's leprosy and this is what in shakespeare's play henry the fourth is described as suffering from we don't really know what it was. Do we know, do academics have a theory about what it actually really was? No, they don't. Because I think there's a general trend now to think that it's quite dangerous to try and use medical records from the past. Partly because they're so inexact and partly I think because it may be that there are kind of illnesses that are no longer current yeah you know they've mutated or changed or whatever whatever it is i
那对我来说似乎是一个泄密点，对吧，法国大革命中的人们，对吧，米拉波，马拉，实际上我们讨论的所有角色都有像脓疱火山口一样的脸，他们都没有处决大主教，或者无论如何还没有处决大主教。是的，所以听众可以自己决定。所以同时代的人说那是麻风病，这就是莎士比亚剧中亨利四世被描述为患有的疾病。我们真的不知道那是什么。我们知道吗，学者们对它到底是什么有理论吗？不，他们没有。因为我认为现在有一种普遍的趋势，认为试图使用过去的医疗记录是非常危险的。部分原因是它们太不准确了，部分原因我认为是因为可能存在某种不再流行的疾病，是的，你知道，它们变异了或改变了，或者无论它是什么，我
mean it it keeps recurring so um in 1408 henry the fourth collapses at mort lake and he's confined to bed for a month january 1409 he has a relapse thinks he's dying and for the rest of it you know the four years that follow that until he does finally die, his health is very, very precarious. But Tom, you don't need to go on about archbishops to explain why this is. I mean, when we described his character, he's been to the Baltic, he's been to the Holy Land, he's led a very, very active, stressful, you know, action-packed life. It's not implausible that as he reaches kind of middle age,
我的意思是它反复发作，所以，嗯，1408年亨利四世在莫特莱克倒下，他被禁足了一个月。1409年1月，他复发了，以为自己快死了，在接下来的四年里，直到他最终去世，他的健康状况非常、非常不稳定。但是汤姆，你不需要一直谈论大主教来解释为什么会这样。我的意思是，当我们描述他的性格时，他去过波罗的海，去过圣地，他过着非常、非常活跃、压力大、你知道，充满行动的生活。当他步入中年时，这并非不可信，
late middle age, his constitution cracks and he begins to pay the price for all his adventures. Yeah, but equally, it might be the hand of God. I mean, either way. Yeah, it might be. Either, well, let's just, you know, leave it open. He's very ill. And so Chris Gibbon Wilson, in his biography of Henry IV, says after 1406, especially after 1408, when he has his relapse, Henry's kingship gradually shaded into Lancastrian family government. And the reason that this is possible is that Henry IV has not just Henry, his eldest son, but three other sons as well. And these are very, very competent people.
步入晚年，他的体质崩溃了，他开始为他所有的冒险付出代价。是的，但同样，它也可能是上帝之手。我的意思是，无论哪种方式。是的，它可能是。无论，好吧，让我们只是，你知道，保持开放。他病得很重。所以克里斯·吉本·威尔逊在亨利四世的传记中说，1406年后，特别是1408年他复发后，亨利的王权逐渐演变为兰开斯特家族的统治。而这之所以可能，是因为亨利四世不仅有亨利，他的长子，还有其他三个儿子。这些人非常、非常能干。
So K.B. Macfarlane, the great historian of the 15th century, really knows what he's writing about. It says that they were the most bookish group of royal princes in medieval England. So they're very literate. They read and they think. But I mean, certainly the three eldest. So Henry, Thomas and John, and the youngest one, Humphrey,
所以K.B.麦克法兰，15世纪的伟大历史学家，非常了解他在写什么。他说他们是中世纪英国最有书卷气的皇室王子群体。所以他们非常有文化。他们阅读和思考。但我的意思是，当然是三个长子。所以亨利、托马斯和约翰，以及最小的汉弗莱，
who will go on to found a famous library. But Henry, Thomas and John are very, very seasoned. They've done a lot of fighting. They're very habituated to how you get things done and they are on hand to keep the show on the road. So in this context, it's unsurprising perhaps that there would be tensions between a very sick Henry and the Prince. And certainly in the last two years of Henry IV's life, there do seem to be tensions. It seems that Henry IV's favorite son was actually Thomas, who becomes the Duke of Clarence. And Henry's enthusiasms are deliberately ignored by Henry
他后来创立了一个著名的图书馆。但亨利、托马斯和约翰非常、非常老练。他们打过很多仗。他们非常习惯于如何把事情做好，他们随时准备让局面保持运转。所以在这个背景下，一个病重的亨利和王子之间出现紧张关系也许并不令人惊讶。当然，在亨利四世生命的最后两年，似乎确实存在紧张关系。亨利四世最喜欢的儿子实际上是托马斯，他后来成为了克拉伦斯公爵。而亨利的狂热被亨利
IV. And so I think that that's where this story of him coming in and trying on the crown works out. So he's ill, he's on his last legs, but he dies in 1415. 1413. With his dynasty secure, with the realm stable, stable. Yeah. Finances, you know, they're never brilliant, but they're in a better shape than they could have been. A lot better than they were. Yeah. His son is able to succeed effectively unchallenged. Yeah. You could argue that this is a remarkable act of political management. Yeah. That he had a really tough gig in 1399.
四世故意忽视了。所以我认为这就是他进来试戴王冠的故事的由来。所以他病了，他快不行了，但他死于1415年。1413年。他的王朝稳固，王国稳定，稳定。是的。财政，你知道，它们从来都不辉煌，但它们处于比可能的情况更好的状态。比以前好多了。是的。他的儿子能够有效地继位，没有受到挑战。是的。你可以说这是一项了不起的政治管理行为。是的。他在1399年接手了一个非常艰难的任务。
And 16 years later, he's done a bloody good job to be where he is. I think you absolutely can. I mean, it really is a formidable record. I think very few people who did what he did, usurp the throne, kill a king, kill an archbishop, would have survived to die in his bed and be succeeded by his son. Yeah. And leave a very, very stable, effective system of government. It's him who dies in the Jerusalem chamber, isn't it? That's right. Yes. You know, he traveled to Jerusalem before he became king
16年后，他能走到今天这一步，做得非常出色。我认为你绝对可以。我的意思是，这确实是一个令人敬畏的记录。我认为很少有人像他那样，篡夺王位，杀害国王，杀害大主教，还能活到在床上去世并由儿子继位。是的。并留下一个非常、非常稳定、有效的政府体系。是他死在耶路撒冷厅，对吧？没错。是的。你知道，他在成为国王之前去了耶路撒冷
and he dreamed of going on crusade. And the story goes that it had been prophesied that he would die in Jerusalem and he thought it meant the city and the Holy Land, but it ends up being this room called Jerusalem in Westminster Abbey. And so he dies there. But I think as well as the fact that he leaves behind an astonishingly stable system of government, there is also a sense that his reign has been very troubled, that it's been a dark time and people do invest their hopes in the young Prince of Wales, who is now Henry V, and hope that his coming to the throne will presage kind of better, nobler, more glorious times. And again, I think that that is something
他梦想着去十字军东征。故事是说，有人预言他会死在耶路撒冷，他以为是指圣地的那个城市，但最终是威斯敏斯特教堂里一个叫耶路撒冷的房间。所以他死在那里。但我认为，除了他留下了一个令人惊讶的稳定政府体系这一事实外，还有一种感觉，即他的统治非常动荡，那是一个黑暗的时期，人们把希望寄托在年轻的威尔士亲王身上，也就是现在的亨利五世，并希望他登上王位能预示着更好、更高尚、更辉煌的时代。同样，我认为这是
that Shakespeare is picking up in this whole story of Falstaff and Henry rejecting him. So should we finish this episode by, do you want to read Henry V's rejection of Falstaff? Because I think it's one of the great speeches in all of Shakespeare and it's the perfect curtain raiser for the series that we'll be doing next week when we look at the reign of Henry V, which has at its centre, of course, the great victory over the French at Agincourt. Well, I think we're all looking forward to that. But just before we get to Agincourt next week, let's have a little bit of Hal and full stuff. So thank you very much, Tom.
莎士比亚在法斯塔夫和亨利拒绝他的整个故事中所捕捉到的东西。那么我们应该以这一集结束吗，你想读亨利五世拒绝法斯塔夫的那段话吗？因为我认为这是莎士比亚所有作品中最伟大的演讲之一，它是我们下周将要进行的系列节目的完美开场白，届时我们将审视亨利五世的统治，当然，其核心是阿金库尔战役中对法国人的伟大胜利。好吧，我想我们都很期待。但在下周到达阿金库尔之前，让我们来一点哈尔和法斯塔夫的内容。所以非常感谢你，汤姆。
That was a, dare I say, a tour de force. Merci. I know thee not, old man, full to thy prayers. How ill white hair's become a fool and jester. I have long dreamed of such a kind of man, so surfeit-swelled, so old and so profane. But being awaked, I do despise my dream. Make less thy body hence, and more thy grace. Leave gormandising. No, the grave doth gape for thee thrice wider than for other men.
那是一场，我敢说，杰作。谢谢。我不认识你，老头，去祈祷吧。白发让一个傻瓜和弄臣变得多么难看。我很久以前就梦想过这样一个人，如此饱食终日，如此年老，如此亵渎。但醒来后，我鄙视我的梦想。从今往后，减少你的身体，增加你的恩典。停止暴饮暴食。不，坟墓为你张开的嘴比为其他人宽三倍。
Reply not to me with a full-born jest. Presume not that I am the thing I was. For God doth know, so shall the world perceive, that I have turned away my former self. So will I those who kept me company. Goodbye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly
不要用一个粗俗的笑话来回答我。不要以为我还是原来的我。因为上帝知道，世界也会察觉到，我已经抛弃了以前的自我。我也会抛弃那些陪伴我的人。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐即一切》。这是你每周
fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。